ゲーム wii クイズグーグルプレイ皆さんこんにちははじめ社長です
グーグルプレイで楽しめるゲームを私たち youtube creator
そしてゲームタイトルにちなんだスペシャルゲストと一緒に遊べちゃう7日間
天の声の肥料や子さんと一緒に進めていきたいとおもいます
費用や時間よろしくお願いしまーすはいいいよろしくお願いします
高
今回紹介するゲームはラブライブスクールアイドルフェスティバルです
こちらのゲームは言わずと知れた第二木スクールアイドルプロジェクトラブライブの
スマホゲーム
プレイヤーは作品の舞台となる音乃木坂学院の生徒となりかわいく個性的なスクール
アイドルグループ
muses のメンバーたちと一緒にライブ活動を通じてがー
こうを盛り上げていくというストーリーに沿って展開される
リズムアクション&アドベンチャーゲームですタッチするタイミングによって
パーフェクト
great good but ミスの5段階の評価が付きます
グレート以上でコンボが続きますので最後までコンボを繋げてフルコンボ目指し
ましょう
わかったわかったわかったわかったし
さらにわかってもらうためだそしてもしかしたらちょっとまだわからないよーっていう
見ている方のためにがちょっとプレイの方してみたいと思うのではい準備の方お願いし
ますはいよろしくお願います
さあ端ションを何をしてるんだい
ここも多い今日ホンギですよかかってこいと言うかって
あっこいいじゃ
じゃあ行ってみたいと思うよはいやっていただきたいのはじゃあ snow
halation
はい
選んだいて難易度はね好きなやつでいいですよ
どうしよういいいいですかああぜんぜんっあの操作方法を説明したティ行きまーお願い
しますえーこちら
ライブパートなんですけども楽曲に明日画面をタップするだけの簡単操作の服所
曲が始まるとを持つ言いたいことに向かって中央からリズムアイコンが飛び出しますの
でタイミングよく
発注してくださいタイミングによってパーフェクト great good but
ミスの順番にね評価がされちゃいますので
あれじゃですよね強い5面を選んでなくていいだいいですから
はーい
シャアホビくしょん怖かったん
よっしゃあああああああああ
あるいは何食ったっけやめてくださいあっはいなんか長押しをしなきゃいけないと言う
これは長尾須藤ですねはいここですね nana を称して
今です花スパーンと素晴らしい
このようにタイミングよくタッチしていきましょう
シンプルですよねねわかりやすいを同時押しですはい
さあ
こういった形で品盆栽ヒント増女子
をでも思いまーてっせたかった送受信ですか
星も奴はタイミング機嫌民じゃないと評価されないん
今のところまったく減る様子がありませんが左上にある緑色のページ
こちらがですね体力ゲージになっておりましてあーーやねぇ
これがなくなってしまうと
4力終了限りなく
月8日のファミーしょうパパ派
いよいよなるな
第に悩むてくださいでしょうかバッハ
どうぞ the pattern なぜミスったか見たミスため
ここで欧米は俺だっておりますユーザーが変な声だけど
voodoo
嫌いじゃないんですよねだからさ
はっはー
更新前団ばペロ友の子見た場所になっちゃう
でもてるって言ってる
素晴らしいパッド連発しておりますねー
曲が終わるまで
やり消えればクリアーということで
この方も
50,000
979ということでお月様でございまーございます
まぁだいたいわかったかな
すごい簡単ですよねうんもう誰でもわかるし
a
ねしかも sl アンテナを模してすごいやりおるきたあんだもう完璧じゃないですか
あんべきっすよ
だじゃあこんな感じで現在の方は進んでいくよーということで覚えて頂ければと思い
ます愛というわけで社員的なスクールアイドルフェスティバルのご紹介をしてきました
が今日は素敵な
ゲストをお招きしておりますう
ん hey
いきますよ図子ぜひなんとミューズからこのさんにお越しいただきましたーーー
今日よ m 嬢
それではを一つ自己紹介をお願いしてもよろしいでしょうか
はいニューズ高坂穂乃果約2対3でしよろしくお願いしますよろしくお願い大
はい東條希言うと記載のですよろしくお願いしまーす
よろしく4
野竿ニコラ空得意そのですよろしくお願いしまーす
肇社長と申します上からよろしくお願いしまーす
恨んねそれを入れていると言えばをおかけになってくださいを受けなください
じゃあ最初にじゃあ皆さんにお聞きしたいんですけれども今は今回の番組
皆さんのことを何と呼びしたら宜しいかなぁなんていうのはありますか
ああそうですねあのーメンバーないでーちゃん呼ばれている
アマネェ今日読んでいただきたいんですけれどもらいーですかはい私は雨えみつんと
呼ばれて3戦無敗
みっつんですよろしくお願いしますよろしくお願いします
あ私はくすんで終われたかすうさんくすーさん
はいよろしくお願います
私のことはそらまる大先生と呼んでくるんですよ
来年というのすごいですかチカチカキャッチはですねでございますね
はじめしゃちょー
なんかいいんですかさっあああああちょっとファンって言うじゃん
ちょっとだけちょちょくんじゃ車ちゃんで多分
ありがとうございますそれを良いですじゃあそうじゃあ呼び合うことによってちょっと
だけ少しでも仲が良くなればなあと
とよろしくお願いしますはぁ
ではちょっとお伺いしたいんですけれども描いつくフェス自体はプレーされたことは
あるでしょうか
あ
もちろんブーンありませんやってるない
なるほどこういうこと聞いちゃっていいんですかねどなたが一番うまいとかってあり
ますか
このな
たらああ
good ああああ
一番進んでますねうーんねっ
あっちですけどうまいかどうかはちょっと
うーん結構いつも行っちゃってる感じですかそうですねあの一時
ずーっとやってましたねあっはっいやー素晴らしいことだと思います
じゃあフルコンボなんかは
フルコン棒はあのハードだったら
まだだったら大丈夫うーんなことだ
なんかよっ行きスパートうわぁああちょっと難しくては難しいよね
じゃあ皆さんにお聞きしたいんですけれども
ハイスクフェスの魅力って何なんでしょうかねぇ
苦しい読むたくさんあるんですけどたしかに一つではもういやらせないそうなんですよ
やっぱりそうですね
もう貼っ客が本当にたくさんありましてねあのーラブライブすごくミューズの歌
たくさんねいいよなーあるねそれのどれたくさん撮れ
聞けちゃうのガーン
すごくいいよね作絵うーん
あと女の子たちがみんな可愛いかー
ハーイんですようんいやそれしますよ
あとはフルボイスで全てストーリーが追従でどんどん
のストーリーも更新されて増えて偶然それもまた楽しみの左がないっていうね
ずっと遊べるもんねー
ブービーてるだけでもうスプーンヌー
いや僕あんまりうまくないんですけどすごい楽しめます下手でも楽しいですし
ございます
チャチャさホームにはどの子をおきたいです同じだ
さーああこれこれ試されてるよ
佐藤と渡部さんですよこれ
car
ああああああ
3212のぞみちゃんですそれじゃあねっ
今日
いやではのアレで当たって sr だったんですよ
スーパーに当たったんでこう強いんだよセンターにおいてますございます
私アンバン望みのスーパーレアとか出ないんですよ
そうですどうしたらいいですかね
いやもういいのですかいぬやしきのスピーチ future だいらっしゃいません
どうみんなやってるんですけどだいたい自分の担当する子が
者がいいんですよ
他の女
能ヶ谷くるのでだりそうねずいぶんのその役今日の女の子は出ないなぜかねぇー
というところでごくださいそろそろお時間の方準備の方がですねと豚2用語ですので
ゲームのプレイの方へ行きたいんですけれども
レイズの皆さんにはひと足先にプレイブースの方へ移っていただきましょう
宜しくお願いします
ビッ
さあ3人がプレイブースに移動している間に放送をご覧になっている方々にはこの
イベントで使用するハングアウト専用アプリゲームエフェクトをご紹介いたします
ゲーム f とはスマホゲームのマルチプレイをいつも以上に楽しむためのいろいろな
機能が詰まった
hangout アプリケーションです例えば好きなゲームキャラのコスチューム
きてプレイを盛り上げたりゲーム中の気持ちの喜怒哀楽を動くスタンプで表現でき
さらには一緒に遊んでる友達に拍手やブーイングなどを送ることもできるんですって
言われてもわからないと思うんで
越冬なんだろうその顔は気になる気になる脇になるは
受賞フェクトですねああ
各社へ降ったらしいんですねこれ
ジャージダイハツいますかはいありがとうございまーそこらへんにパソコンがはいあり
ますか
ありました ok でございます今ねそこにある
画面こちらがですね google さんが提供するハンガーとっていうビデオ
チャットツールです
いやいやグーグル+アカウントは持っている方ならば誰でも無償で使うことができるん
ですよ
で
ゲイ免許となんですけどもこのハンガーとを使いながら楽しむアプリなんですね
ということでございまして早速ちょっといろいろいじってみましょうかはいえーと
コスチュームのタブの中にまあいろいろとあると思うんですねですね
銀杏やつポチっと押してみて
どうするかな内部ない6
今日は the これこれでをあーやーよいいよ業
いようハピでしょてっかー
全然できる知多はて落こういうのはこの憧れるんですよねまして会でもそういうタイプ
でしょ
いや全然違いますよインドア系なんで1泊てられたほかのもうちょっと選んでみるうえ
質な
がどんなのがあるかなぁみたいので
インナー列があったら結局こういうのが面白いんですよね
こういうんですよね秋田あああああああっ
下手で誰だいいじゃないのちゃんと筆記にも対応しているという
ちゃんとあの顔を認識して追尾してくれるんですよ
夏なんだ戦う前なのかなパクシフさんニョクこれでいきますじゃ好きなんだけど
スタッフ
とっていうタブがあると思うんですねはいこちらのほうしていただくと喜怒哀楽を a
社屋スタンプが表現してくれるということで
じゃあ例えば家愛とかを気合い
んじゃないポストっをした
お腹あうねうん多いですよねこういうぽ一方
ピザ出陣じゃーんたいなあーすごい
他には涙とかありますをそれはに合うパンツがは愛想
陣地取られちゃったあおちーブザーがオシャレ
まあまあこういう感じでねやるんですけど
も速いことだに突っ込みっていうねハッハッ
やる気満々じゃないですかあるんですがこちらの方
まあ今いるのがブーイングがあるんですが実際にこれは自分にやるものではなくてです
ね
お友達に対してやるものでございます寂しいじゃ僕の方から始めしてを込めてみたいと
思います褒めてくださいはいそうするのですね
じゃあよかったぁーか
画動はいこんな感じだったりと取れないとかを安く買おう
こんなエフェクトがありますじゃあ逆にちゃったーーーーはじめじゃ何やってんです
かーっていう時には
ブーイングっていうので
高
ってこうねあかーんたカンカンはい
でさらにはアーナナ仕置き
ボリビアですやっぱり
というようなものがございますのでぜひこういった形でより円滑なコミュニケーション
をそして
遊んで頂ければと思いますのでよろしくお願いしまーす出て分かった
わかりましたパッケージじゃあ準備をと思ったようなので
肇社長さん chat さん廃プレイブースで移動お願いしまーす
入ってきますから
ああああああ
いいえ
しています